okay we're coming up on the time so I'm
going to
start
a program
recording in progress
and I'm going to start our live stream
for our LinkedIn audience
got it
all right
so welcome to
this career information session in which
you'll learn about the cloud computing
boot camp from Caltech Center for
technology and management education my
name is Stuart Creek I am with simply
learn we are the delivery partner
for Caltech for this program so
let's get started I'm going to
tell you about cloud computing careers
we have a substitution and our auxiliary
speaker Mike Ash is not available today
but I will be sharing with you some
comments from one of our senior
instructors
about how this boot camp prepares you
uh we'll talk about learner outcomes
and share with you enrollment steps
including a bonus offer for those of you
who are here today because
uh you showed up to the webinar so
stay tuned for that
we'll I'll take your questions toward
the end please put those into the Q and
A box if you are on our streaming
service you can put those into the
chatter comment box of your streaming
service LinkedIn YouTube and um
should be able to get those over to me
but
I'll take the questions toward the end
if you're on the zoom session please put
those into the Q a
and uh the about you part is where I'm
going to be asking you some polls along
the way to learn a bit a little bit more
about you in the audience so
with that let's get started
well about careers in cloud computing
and I assume that you're all here
because you are interested in pursuing
your career in cloud computing they're
already in the field or whether you're
going to enter the field
but cloud computing is the backbone of
the digital economy it's what makes
everything possible from the apps on our
mobile devices
to software as a service
to all of the
many
websites that we go to from social media
to e-commerce
to banking to everything else that we do
and it's the reason why when the
pandemic hit we were all able to
transition to work from home
or at least all of us that we're told to
we're able to make that transition
because
cloud computing allows for not only the
distribution of information over uh
networks that form the cloud but also
commoditized storage and commoditized
Computing and
distribution so that companies that want
to start
businesses in the digital space
no longer have to build out a huge data
center mainframe computers in order to
serve a global audience do it by going
to
friendly cloud provider Amazon or
Microsoft Azure or Google cloud or any
of several others and asking them to
just provision you
virtual Computing Services storage
services and network access on an as
needed basis
and the wonderful thing is that it's
also scalable so that you're able to
handle jumps in demand if things that
you have invented becomes the next hot
shiny object that everybody has to have
then you're able to scale up very
quickly because of cloud services
and also of course companies like Amazon
are able to scale Up and Down based on
seasonal
um demand so
cloud computing has really transformed
the world and especially within the last
several years
um along with the software as a Services
Market
um which is going to
granted to 120 billion dollars
we're looking at these numbers these are
from last year so you need to update
these but um
the the markets are
growing at a credible pace so
you know 300 billion dollars
we're on a pace to hit a half a trillion
dollars within the next several years
so it's a huge field it's very growing
field and every company depends on it
so you have the ability
to pursue a number of different career
paths
cloud computing field you can be a cloud
architect once you've gained experience
and understand how to configure the
infrastructure and match it to the needs
of the organization along the way you
can be a cloud engineer a cloud
developer uh you can specialize in
database distributed Cloud databases you
can specialize in security or the devops
cycle
for software development and deployment
in the cloud environment so all of
of these skills I should it says
blockchain but it should be Cloud
um
all of these skills open up create
career paths for you
so you need up-to-date skills to be a
cloud practitioner to be effective in
the industry you need
what's called a t-shaped skill set which
is a broad understanding of the cloud
computing field
and then deep understanding of whichever
area you want to specialize in
so being able to select among Cloud
providers because you have a number of
different options between public cloud
services or configuring private cloud
services
application migration to move
existing
traditional non-cloud services to the
cloud environment the performance
testing and workload modeling
security for identity access management
the database security Disaster Recovery
Auto scaling to handle the surges and
demand that I mentioned
um understanding how the database
management is done differently when it's
distributed in the cloud environment
um being able to do things like
multi-cloud deployment mixing and
matching and storage services
understanding how those are provisioned
so
you need to have a broad range of skills
in order to
be successful because then you can
understand what
role your particular specialty plays
within that range
so let me ask a question of our audience
start
what's stopping you
and I'm curious to know why you haven't
enrolled in a program of this type so
far
is it because you can't find one that
covers all those skills we talked about
is it because you don't have the
confidence that you'd end up with
practical experience that you could use
to demonstrate new skills
is it because your learning style
doesn't work with
watching videos
or is it because you haven't found time
in your work schedule
I'm going to let this run for another
five seconds and I'll close the poll
get your answers in and
here we go
so the main
worry that people have is that they
wouldn't get a practical experience out
of a program that would that they would
then be able to use to show off
to their employer or a prospective new
employer
and that makes sense because if you are
learning from
pre-recorded videos kind of a self-paced
isolation mode
um it's kind of difficult to to
develop a portfolio of projects so we'll
talk about that
because
this program is designed differently
this program is designed as an online
boot camp
delivered entirely online so you can
access it from
anywhere in your
in your life you can go from laptop
desktop and even access the materials on
your mobile device
um but the curriculum which I'll
describe is a comprehensive curriculum
it's aligned to the needs of Industry
Caltech ctme Works directly with many
companies and trained there staff and
Executives and
they understand
needs that companies have for the skill
sets the people they hire so this is why
they've designed this curriculum in this
way
the online environment is completely
integrated so that you take your classes
live online through that environment you
access all of your study materials
online in that environment and you do
your labs and projects online in that
environment so you don't have to acquire
a separate system
in order to be able to do that but you
do have online virtual live classrooms
where you interact directly with your
instructors ask them questions they ask
you questions
and you can interact with your
classmates
and you meet with them on a basically a
weekly basis Saturday and Sundays four
hours each
and then in the between time between
Class sessions you have the ability to
do all of your prep work and class work
and projects
on your own schedule
you're working at three o'clock in the
morning but if you happen to be doing
that and you find them across some type
of
question that stumps you or that you
need help with we have a 24x7 support
system that allows you to interact not
only with your peers but with other
instructors and with our 24x7 help desk
they ask about
subject matter or or to deal with any
issues that you might have using the
platform so
you get full support you can take this
course on your schedule
it requires you to plan for about 10 to
15 hours a week
for six months
but it's something that you can fit into
almost any working lifestyle so
with that
I need to make a quick check of
something
second
all right here we go
um sorry about that
let's talk about what you get at the end
of the process
and at the end of the process
you have a certificate from Caltech
that certifies that you have completed
all the core courses satisfactorily that
you've done all the project work and
that you've done the all-important
Capstone project which gives you
something to put in your portfolio to
demonstrate that you have
in fact mastered the skills of computing
so this is
not only a certificate but it is backed
up with a portfolio of your work that
you can show as your practical
experience
Caltech offers you 15
credits of
uh
continuing education units is that
hold on a second
and
15 education CEUs are for people who are
in a
um
a field or a job that requires you to
show your employer or to show regulatory
agencies or government bodies that you
are
um continuing your education on an
ongoing basis
so
you for example have a professional
license and need to show that you've
gotten a certain amount of continuing
education to keep that license
this is a CE user for
um Caltech CT math circle membership is
an online Alumni Association that
network with people who have gone
through oops Caltech training ctme
programs so that's a great benefit and
we will recognize you at an online
convocation where the program director
will call you out by name this is
something where you can invite your
friends and family to see you being
honored for your accomplishment
um last but not least we offer you
career assistance and I'll describe that
in more detail
Caltech ctme is a part of Caltech
California Institute Institute of
Technology 130 year old private
Institution
is not part of the California University
of California system or California State
University system
the private institution it specializes
in research so very few undergraduates
mostly graduate students and
research Labs that includes the
um
jet propulsion lab of NASA where
satellites and deep space probes are
designed and developed built so it's
pretty amazing institution and if you
are a fan of the television show with
big bad Theory
there's a reason why they set it at
Caltech because that's where the best
and the brightest congregate one of the
places in the world where you find a
very high concentration of Nobel Prize
winners people who earned their Nobel
Prize for research they did at Celtic or
who earned a Nobel Prize and then went
to Caltech to further their research
um consistently reacts in the top five
universities worldwide
and it's something that people will
recognize on your resume so
very valuable addition
to your personal
CV
so this is a boot camp program
and it's pretty special because it has
very open requirements not
um a postgraduate program this is a
program that's opened to anyone who has
a high school diploma
and it's at least 18 years of age and
who has the aptitude and desire
to work in cloud computing you do not
have to have prior work experience
you don't even have to have programming
experience because all of the
programming skills that you need will be
provided to you as part of the program
if you need some basic understanding we
have
pre-courses that will get you up to
speed at that level and then within the
program itself you'll be learning
whatever programming and scripting
languages you need to use so with that
I'm going to ask another question if I
may
and this one is what is your level of
experience
so are you currently
uh studying for say your bachelor's
degree are you
in the workforce and if you're in the
workforce how long have you been
that refers to any formal work
experience not
specifically cloud computing
I'm going to let this run for about
another 10 seconds as people get their
answers in
and we'll close the poll in five four
three
two one
and so
almost 90 percent of the folks are out
of school in the workforce
with half of you
with more than five years of experience
so this is a
seasoned audience
share with you how this program works
for you as well as for people who are
brand new
industry
how the program prepares you and what
I'm going to do is describe the program
and then I'm going to have one of our
senior instructors
uh share with you a tour of the learning
environment itself so first let's talk
about the uh
curriculum and I mentioned
you need a comprehensive curriculum to
cover all the skills that you might want
to use in cloud computing so that you
can then have a solid foundation for
specializing
in a particular area
so this program starts with an
orientation session which is sort of
virtual freshman orientation it it shows
you the learning environment how to
control it where to find your curriculum
how to navigate through that where to
find your live classes your study
materials your project uh
lab environment how to use all of that
how to access your support well uh
that's a basic orientation and then once
you've gotten that you move into
Cloud fundamentals
chosen AWS as the first platform
expose you to because of course AWS is
the largest of the platforms at this
point
um but this will give you the uh
a practical Foundation of how cloud
computing works
then you'll move into designing
applications and architectures in AWS
which means you'll be given challenges
to to create actual cloud computing
environments that are useful for
particular industry aligned problem
the exercises will
get you
familiar with the tools and how to use
them to set up different Cloud
environments well
because Azure is also extremely
important will expose you to the Azure
environment
giving you
um
the differences and similarities between
the two
you'll then move into doing the same
types of functions in Azure Microsoft
environment
and then we'll move on to signing
infrastructure Solutions in Azure which
will take you a bit deeper into how do
you create larger Cloud infrastructure
for your organization
figure that
based on the organization's needs it's
geographic distribution all those other
factors
that leads into the final module which
is the cloud computing Capstone project
in this Capstone project which I'll
describe a little bit more detail later
you will pick a problem from several
different options based on different
industry domains and real world
challenges that companies face you'll
pick one of those as a case study that
you will then
design and build
the cloud computing solution that solves
that problem it's about a three to four
week process it's done under the
mentorship of your one of your
instructors
and that be sent becomes essentially not
only your final project for creating
your certificate awarded but it also
becomes something in your portfolio that
use to demonstrate
to anyone you care to that you have the
skills in cloud computing and the
experience to back those up
along the way you have electives one
type of elective or the periodic
academic master classes where Caltech
instructors come in and talk to you
about
more depth about
topics in the industry
you also have the ability to call on
your instructors for office hours and
for what we call Project hours which are
specifically for you to consult with
them on how your projects are going if
you have a project you've been working
on that you've reached a point where the
dead end or gone down a rabbit hole they
can help you with that
so
along the way you will be using a number
of different tools so it's important to
know that you'll be using them not
simply be
exposed to them
watching videos about how they work
you'll you'll be required
to take these tools and Implement
projects in the end
Solutions through them so the end of the
process when you put these and many
other tools on your resume you'll be
able to say
I know how to use them and here are
examples of how I've done it so
that's extremely valuable
aspect of the boot camp style of
learning
so just to reiterate about the Capstone
project you're going to to presented
with several different choices
different industry domains
um and you'll be able to pick one that
you'll focus on you'll focus on that for
three to four weeks you'll meet with
your instructor weekly review your
progress get advice on how to move
forward if you have any issues
and
at the end of that process you'll have a
complete solution to the problem
which will be submitted for grading and
which will be part of your permanent
portfolio
show off future so we're really uh very
proud of this part of our
learning model
so here is where I'm going to ask
hershitam
have play a video recorded
um he has a assistant professor
um
he specializes in cloud computings and
he's a Google Scholar so
uh he is one of our senior instructors
this is the type of person you'll be
learning from
um
some of them from India some of them
from the United States some of them from
other countries but all of them with
industry experience
um and expertise so at this point I'm
going to
share with you his tour of the learning
management system
thank you
Shannon quickly
yes guys
so uh
very warm welcome and thank you through
it for giving me the opportunity yeah
guys so welcome everyone a very good
evening to all of you and good morning
to uh all uh others those who are in
different time zones as well so I'm
Pursuit masudani and Stuart has already
given my introduction so I'm working as
an assistant professor and I'm working
as an assistant professor in uh Baba
College of engineering and management
nagpur India and I've been working as a
lead trainer with simply learn uh in the
Caltech batches
so let's get into the things uh
right so
I'll just try to explain you how this
works
right so
see how this program works so guys uh
you when you register for this Caltech
program so it's a 11 months program and
it starts with AWS Cloud fundamentals
right so that is the first course that
uh you'll get into AWS Cloud
fundamentals
um you do and then
um you go with designing applications in
architecture in AWS so basically AWS
architect associate uh program you go
with that is a 40 hours course
10 days or four hours each Saturday
Sunday so
um 40 hours course then you go with
Azure Cloud fundamentals
um then you go with designing
infrastructure Solutions on Azure which
is again uh for TR course right um so
that is how it goes and then that is AZ
303 and then you go with Implement
manage and monitor on Azure Azure
environment that is azure design
Solutions so that is is it 304 so that
is again a 40R course so this is how it
is spanned out now
um I'll give you the live demonstration
of the LMS here and basically it would
be very very clear with that how it goes
so this is the postgraduate program in
cloud computing so if we go to this
program
you can see that as I have already told
you so in the courses uh the first
course you have is orientation session
for Caltech pgp Cloud program if we go
inside that you have self learning
videos which are there plus uh you will
have live learning live classes as well
right then the second program comes out
to be AWS Solutions uh second course in
this comes out to be AWS Solutions
architect associate as I said now in
this when you go you have self learning
videos which are the pre-recorded videos
by an already available instructor then
there is another tab in the live in the
LMS that you will find that is live
classes now in these live classes uh you
will see the recordings of the live
classes so as I said it would be a 40
hours course
um every weekend a four four hours like
eight hours Saturday Sundays so the
recordings of those live classes we will
appear here
and you can always listen to it it would
be available for your lifetime and apart
from that you can also listen to self
learning videos from an already
available instructor like some other
instructor the videos are already there
plus live classes recordings will be
available in the live classes tab then
there is something called as practice
labs
and see in this live classes tab you
have my classes wherein you will see the
recordings of your ongoing class plus uh
you will see the available classes to
which you can register for and the past
classes recordings like if you have done
some classes so the recordings of those
will appear here then you have the
practice lab session here now in this
practice Labs you can just launch the
lab and once you launch the lab you can
start doing the lab in this sandbox
environment correct so you don't need to
have your personal account even if you
want to do the lab you can do it in the
sandbox environment that is provided by
simply learn here so you can just start
the lab and you can keep start doing the
labs and as rightly stated by Stuart
that it would not be just that the
instructors would be telling you
something in theory it would be Concepts
plus practical plus Hands-On and you
would also be do doing it
in many of the labs along with the
instructor the labs so this lab
environment will help you to launch your
lab and do the labs which would be taken
up by the instructors then
there is assessment part so in the
assessment part there will be a project
that you will have to complete in order
to
um I mean complete this course now this
project will be taken up by the
instructor on the last day of your this
course uh so you along with the
instructor would be doing this project
so instructor will help you out in doing
this project so that you successfully
complete it and you
at the end of the program you will get a
certificate from the Caltech right but
even when you complete each and every
course after each course you can unlock
the corresponding certificate for that
particular course like when you complete
AWS Solutions architect course so you
can unlock this certificate now the
necessary condition to unlock the
certificate is that either you should
complete 85 percent of the self learning
videos or 80 of the live classes you can
satisfy any of these condition plus
apart from this you'll also have to
complete the project so as I shown you
in the assessment part there are two
projects so you have to complete one out
of the two projects and and you also
have to complete at least one out of the
three simulation tests that are given in
the assessment section with sixty
percent uh marks right so now in the
assessment section when you'll see so
this project uh one out of the two
project you'll have to complete and the
instructor will help you out to do it
during your last class in fact you will
do it along with the instructor
and of course he'll also help you out in
doing these tests so I mean in providing
uh the uh required knowledge that you
want to complete this test and to score
um uh that score in a manner so that you
should be able to unlock your
certificate right so uh these tests you
will have to give one out of the three
simulation test plus one out of the two
projects
Plus either 85 percent of the self
learning videos or eighty percent of the
live learning classes if you will
complete then you will be able to unlock
the certificate for AWS Solutions
architect associate so that is there
now apart from this when you complete
this course then you will move further
and uh you would register yourself for
uh Microsoft Azure architect
Technologies now again in this uh you
will have the same thing the self
learning videos then the live classes
live classes would be taken by the
instructor you'll see the recordings
here of that then again practice Labs so
even if you don't have the Azure account
you don't need it guys because
simplyleon is providing you with the
labs so that you can launch the labs and
you can do the program and do your
practicals your Hands-On activity in
this simply learn Azure Labs then in the
assessment part of uh Azure this thing
you will have
again a project and a test paper two
test papers here now uh you will have to
to unlock the certificate you will have
to do the project okay uh so that is
what um you will have to do and plus
apart from that you should be completing
uh either 85 percent of the
self-learning videos or 80 of the live
classes and then you will be able to
unlock the certificate for uh Microsoft
Azure AZ 303 so this is what you go with
then once you are done with this then
you will go with the designing Solutions
on Azure course and in this the pattern
again uh would would remain the same
guys so you will have to either go with
the self-learning videos and and it's up
to you like see I would prefer you go
with both the things that is self
learning plus live classes so both are
given to you but to unlock the
certificate uh the prerequisites you
should have at least 85 percent of self
learning or 80 of the life classes
completed plus the project in AZ 304
again right so that is there and again
the instructor will help you out to um
do your project uh during the last class
of that course okay so that is there and
again you are provided with the practice
labs and let me tell you guys one more
thing here that the labs that would be
taken or the Hands-On activity that
would be taken in your classes see that
is going to be
um like
um we people out here we take real
scenarios okay it's not like that very
simple Labs we take we take it from
simple to scenario based Labs so that
you are good uh and you have the real
experience that will not just help you
to clear the certification but that will
help you in your uh working in your real
operation in the industries right so
that Real Environment we try to provide
you when we take the labs on our
platform here in simply learn okay so
that is there
okay then uh so uh you that way you
complete uh Azure uh AWS architect Azure
architect 303 and Azure architect design
304 and finally uh you will have to
complete a Capstone project and uh when
you go to the Capstone project again
um in that there is an introduction so
that is self learning or in that there
is an assessment so in this assessment
uh you are being given you can see there
are four problem statements out here and
I can just read out the problem
statements here for you guys that is
deploying an online movie watching
application on cloud or deploying an
online Doctors Clinic application on
cloud deploying a restaurant application
to Cloud employing cart management
application to Cloud so this is an
end-to-end project that you will be
doing as a part of your Capstone project
now of course if you have to unlock this
certificate of Capstone project then you
should be attending 80 percent of the
live classes
um there will be one live class only
there'll be a three hour session in
which the instructor would be doing this
Capstone project for you and you will be
doing it along with the instructor so
you should be completing 80 of that live
class uh attendance plus apart from that
you should be completing one out of
these four projects so out of these four
projects one will be taken by the
instructor during that live class now it
would be an end-to-end project as I told
you and now by this time you should be
good in AWS and Azure both services so
you can do this project by either using
the AWS services or the Azure services
so that will depend on you and as well
as the instructor so instructor can take
it up on AWS or assure and you can do it
along with that as well so um so
actually there will be two classes so
one would be taken for AWS and one would
be taken for Azure so one instructor
will take it on AWS one on Azure and the
instructor can on AWS can take any of
these problem statements instructor on
Azure can take up any of these problem
statements you will for unlocking the
certificate you'll have to complete at
least one project out of this force uh
to unlock the certificate plus eighty
percent of the
or more sessions of One Life Class that
is what is the requirement and that is
how is the LMS goes uh so once you are
done with all these things guys uh that
is the um orientation session you attend
then the AWS Solutions architect
associate course then Azure architecture
Technologies Azure architect design and
then the Capstone project once you are
done with all these things guys you will
be able to unlock your PG program
certificate and just hold on see this is
what is the uh compulsory stuff okay
these are the compulsory courses that
you will have to attend and you will
have to clear so to unlock your PG
program certificate finally also apart
from the individual course certificates
apart from these courses guys there are
some electives also now as far as the
electives are concerned uh it is up to
you uh you can register for these
electives also and you can start
learning these electives as well so as
far as the elect are concerned so they
have provided you with the Caltech ctme
cloud computing master classes as
rightly pointed out by Stuart so they'll
be the master classes by the Caltech
professors and you can attend them plus
apart from that uh you will have a
Microsoft Azure administrator 104 so
again see these elective courses these
are not mandatory but if you do attend
it then you can do the self learning in
this of course or you can do the live
learning classes also with the um
instruct and the recordings would be
available here and the same way you have
labs and assessment part in this and you
can unlock the individual certificate
for this elective course by uh either
doing again 85 percent of self learning
or 80 of the live classes plus the
project and of course the project would
be handled by the instructor during your
last class of this elective class so
um you have elective
um
courses on
uh what you have the electives on uh
ez104 that is azure administrator
associate then is it 204 that is
Microsoft certified Azure developer
associate uh then you have AWS developer
associate AWS sysops associate AWS
database migration Google Cloud platform
architect and guys let me tell you if
you go to any of these courses the
pattern for unlocking the certificate
Remains the Same and the pattern of
learning Remains the Same out there
right in some courses there is just self
learning given and you can unlock the
certificate by uh doing 85 percent of
the self-learning classes like Google
Cloud platform architect and in the
others like I feel go to the others uh
that is see ews database migration
in that
you have self learning and then you can
uh
unlock the certificate if you do again
85 of the self learning videos and then
apart from that let me just scroll to
the others also
so if we go to the
AWS Sops associate
so in that you have live classes plus
length learning and you can again unlock
the certificate by doing the live
classes all self-learning videos plus
the project and assessment right so
that's how it goes plus apart from this
for two zero four and one zero four also
uh you have and AWS developer associate
also you have self learning plus the
live uh classes that you can attend okay
guys so this is what uh is all about the
LMS not just this thing uh plus apart
from that guys if you go to this
community Tab out here so this is really
interesting and this is really useful I
would say so there is a community Forum
now during your course like if you have
any any queries you can ask it during
the class uh to the instructor and the
instructor will try to answer all of
your queries apart from that if you come
across any query after the class like
when you are doing your lab and if
you're not understanding anything if you
come across any query after the class so
what you can do is you can put your
questions in the community Forum here
and they would be answered by the
technical team uh in simply learn right
so you don't have to worry even after
the class if you have queries you can
just raise your queries and your queries
will be answered guys so you have the
community forum for the same
okay so that is there uh so that's there
plus in in my resources uh you can see
the uh blogs uh that are being posted on
different activities you can just go
through that as well if you wish to of
course this is not a compulsory activity
but if you are interested you can go
through the blocks that are posted for
different uh topics that you can always
go through right guys so uh that is what
um is the uh what I can say the uh
overview of the LMS okay and what
courses you will be offered in the cloud
computing and how you can attend them
and then
um what would be the completion criteria
for those courses so this is what I have
told you guys
thank you
so
first ChatOn give you a pretty thorough
demonstration of the learning
environment and all of its different
aspects
and the program is run
by Caltech ctme under the direction of
Rick Heffner
the overall program director for the
center and John wetch who is the
director for the cloud computing program
um these are gentlemen who have great
deal of experience in industry
several decades and
experiencing higher education
government Consulting so these are folks
who know the material know the needs of
industry and Academia both together and
have designed this this curriculum
to prepare you for entering the industry
and succeeding
talk a little bit about learner outcomes
where the people come from in these
batches who you'll be learning alongside
um you'll be learning alongside people
who come not only from Information
Technology and software but also from
Finance banking e-commerce industry
Manufacturing
so you'll be
learning alongside people from a lot of
different companies and backgrounds and
do an opportunity
to network with your fellow classmates
um get exposed to
many different
opportunities out in the in the
workplace
so we're very proud of that in fact as
well that companies send their people to
this program
to become Cloud certified
I mentioned that we have a career assist
service and that extends for six months
after the end of the boot camp
this is a
in conjunction with a company called
Talent Inc it includes not just their
services but also access to a webinar
program that we run where we provide
career webinars and
expert
speakers on an ongoing basis
we also
considered the the project portfolio
that you developed during your your boot
camp as part of your career assist
because that's something that you then
use to demonstrate your experience and
then the job assist Services formally
consist of access to the uh Talent Inc
job portal called resume rabbit which
allows you to apply for an exclusive set
of jobs from them
through their employer Network and that
gives you complete confidentiality and
privacy as you
apply
so that your current employer doesn't
know what's going on
these that's a valuable service but I in
my opinion the other two parts of the
service are more valuable the resume
review and rewrite is important because
in today's environment resumes have to
go through an automated tracking system
uses AI to filter out
matches between
job descriptions and resume content so
in order to pass that filter and be
matched up your resume has to be
formatted in a way that the AI bot can
read it
and in a way that it can recognize what
your skill sets and experience are
compared to the
job description
that is uh
challenge in itself and then the second
part of it of course is the resume still
ends up going in front of human beings
on their screen or on their desktop so
it still has to be attractive to them
from that perspective so making a resume
that
achieves both of those objectives is
kind of an art form and that's what this
resume review and rewrite service helps
you with
um
professional writer who will
take you through that process draft your
resume and help you fine tune it for
those purposes and then the same thing
about interview Services you have
one-on-one sessions where you practice
the many different types of interviews
that you'll encounter once you are
called in
um you'll have phone screens that you'll
have to pass you'll have
direct interviews which are either over
Zoom or or in person
some of them will be for your new
technology skills in cloud computing
some of them will be for your fit with
company culture management styles and
that type of thing so you have to be
prepared for all those types of resin
interviews and the interview service
will it will help you with all of that
as well so we think that those are
extremely valuable to you again they
extend for six months after you complete
the boot camp
and this is not a job guarantee program
this is a program to help you with your
job search so
I mentioned the expert webinars you
have webinars with people who are
technology experts who will go into
details about particular Technologies or
about
the industry in general or will help you
with job search
skills or with
career planning skills so all of those
things are
available to you these are free webinars
on an ongoing basis
so to be able to ask those access those
for a lifetime and
talked about the different applications
and um
for the project is
uh Christian Tom shared with you you
have the four different choices for your
Capstone project
and
this the one you choose will become your
final
examine the program but also your
showpiece for future employers
so we can share with you the next
program
the Boot Camp starts on February 18th so
this weekend we can start classes with
an induction session tomorrow if you
want to start as quickly as that of
course there are other sessions coming
after
um but this is the soonest one you can
join the cost of the program is nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine
dollars U.S
and it can be financed for as low as 880
a month that is zero cost financing for
12 months
um but for being here today as I
promised there is a bonus so if you sign
up from this webinar
you will be able to claim a 500 discount
the cost of the program so that will
reduce both the total cost in the
monthly payments
and
I'm going to share with you in the chat
the link to our program page as well as
to
the email ask us at simplylearn.net
you're with me as I put that into our
chat box
and
there you go
at this point based on what you've heard
so far are you interested in
enrolling in this program
I'll leave this open for about 10
seconds it's a yes or no question
foreign
so two-thirds of our audience are
interested in the program I will share
with you how
uh how that works steps are that you
need to take
and it's very straightforward you
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
be sure to mention that you attended the
webinar
have earned the 500 discount
and
they will review your your criteria
again this is the boot camp program the
criteria are very straightforward
um you may get a simple assessment test
that talks about your aptitude in
technology and your desire to pursue
this program
um but based on that we'll send you a
letter of admission
start as soon as this weekend
and on that subject how soon are you
interested in starting this program
so we'll let this go for again another
10 seconds
okay here we go
almost half of you are interested in
doing this within the next three months
perhaps not starting this weekend but
uh in March or April
and for those of you who are looking to
start this further out please contact us
and ask us at simplylearn.net
so that we can keep in touch with you
answer any questions you have
and at this point I'm going to take your
questions
quickly go to uh where we've been
accumulating some of these questions
um
do you need to have basic programming
language skills to learn
cloud computing
again you do not have to have that in
order to join the program in the program
itself you will be exposed to different
scripting languages and tools a lot of
cloud computing is essentially
non-coding so
um
don't have to come in with that you'll
get everything you need during the the
boot camp
um
question from kalyani is can AI
Innovation make cloud computing
obviously
uh that's an interesting question
um there is something called Cloud AI
it is a discipline within cloud
computing for applying AI techniques to
things like resource allocation
and it's an area that you can pursue
after this program so
um we don't think that AI is going to
make
anything really obsolete it's going to
make it possible for people to
accomplish more using AI tools
see if I can
get one of the other questions we have
here
someone who's asked I mean project
management looking to become a project
manager for cloud migration is that
possible
I guess that is that is definitely
possible your project management skills
will be extremely useful uh in the cloud
in the context of cloud computing
um since cloud computing often
requires implementation of new
architectures or new infrastructures
having that background in project
management
gives you an advantage
understanding how to organize that work
and schedule it in
make sure that it gets accomplished
um
philippas
I want to specialize in databases it's
on the cloud is this the right program
for me I think this is the right program
for uh getting the foundation you need
to do that you will
be exposed to how databases in the cloud
differ from other architectures and
you'll get the understanding you need of
cloud computing environments so that
in future if you want to go deeper into
Cloud database management you'll have
the solid foundation for that all right
in my opinion yes this is a great
program for you to start with
um
what are the chances of lending Cloud
Solutions positions after the completion
of the program
so
um
again we offer you the the
career assistance
for six months so we're helping you um
as much as we can with that and what
we've found and why the Consulting
foreign young has actually found that
ninety percent of the people who take
training through simply learn achieve
their objectives
and we're very proud of that fact so we
do not offer a guarantee of finding a
job but we do offer you a good track
record of helping people with that and a
good track record
uh of
um accomplishment first
Learners accomplishing with that
um
take another look here to see of
what time will the live lectures be
these are usually timed at
8 A.M to noon on Saturdays and Sundays
um
not sure what that is in Universal time
I know what that is uh
that would in India that would be uh
9 30 pm
that you'd have to translate with your
world clock
and
I think that that covers those
things I think we had one other
question I'm trying to look up the
answer for you real quick
we had if you we had a question about
average earnings
or Cloud Solutions are architect
and I think the best place to look that
up is uh to go to indeed
uh or Glassdoor
and see
um what the
first rates salaries are in your area
uh
they tend to be pretty high the average
annual salary according to Glassdoor for
people in cloud computing
this is not necessarily for people at
the entry level but average out annual
salary in the U.S is 130k annually
so it's a
big number
it's a great field it's growing
the
you think it's an excellent career
choice
and with that
I think we have covered
another question from an anonymous
attendee we'll try to to uh
if you would email me with that question
because you have a specific personal
issue
um
you email me
ask us at simplylearn.net or
stuart.creek at simplylearn.net and we
will make sure we follow up on that
because I want to make sure that we're
doing
uh
your concern is attended to so
with that I'm going to complete
the webinar
and we'll complete one last question
this last question is do you need
assistance with enrollment
and if you would like to get a
certificate of attendance for today's
session
please answer yes because we can send
that out to you
but otherwise if you are
if you need help from ask us simply
learn.net
of all the questions
let us know we will contact you
and I'll leave this open for just
another three seconds
okay
about 60 percent of you
are interested in getting information so
we will
handle that and
we want to Welcome All of You Into the
simply learned Learning Community uh
with Caltech ctme
um
we hope to see you in a boot camp in
future
and we hope to uh
help you succeed in your cloud computing
career so please contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net to get the process
started or to ask any final questions
you have
QR code will take you to the program
page
and with that
we conclude our webinar for today so
again thank you all for being here